GLOBALISTS DISMANTLING NATIONAL
DEMOCRACIES AND IMPORTING
NONWHITE IMMIGRANTS TO
HISTORICALLY WHITE COUNTRIES.
VICTOR, YOU LIVE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY OF CALIFORNIA, THE BREAD
BASKET OF THE UNITED STATES.
BUT THEY WANT TO SHUT DOWN
DEBATE HERE AND SAY IT'S JUST
THE RIGHT WINGERS WHO ARE JUST
TRYING TO PROTECT THE FARMERS IN
THE NETHERLANDS.
LIKE WHAT IS THIS REALLY ABOUT,
VICTOR?
>> IT'S PRETTY PATHETIC, IT'S A
PATHETIC USE OF A GOVERNMENT
CONTROL BY A SMALL ELITE.
THEY CAN'T ADDRESS THE
EXISTENTIAL PROBLEM THAT CHINA
AND INDIA ARE POLLUTING --
CONTRIBUTING 40% OF THE GREEN
HOUSE GAS RELEASES OR THE LEAKS
ARE CONTRIBUTED TO IT BY THE
PRIVATE JET TRAVEL AND THEY PICK
ON 17,000 DUTCH FARMERS, I MEAN,
MY GOD, THESE PEOPLE ARE THE
MOST EFFICIENT DAIRY FARMERS IN
THE WORLD, THEY HAVE A GLOBAL
REPUTATION FOR LAND STEWARDSHIP.
WE WERE TOLD ALL DURING THE 90s,
LAURA, WE HAVE TO GO BACK TO
ORGANIC AND NATURAL FARMING, TOO
MUCH CHEMICAL NITRATES AND THE
DAIRY BECAME THE NEXUS WHERE
EVERYBODY LOOKS FOR ORGANIC
MANURES TO BE SUPPLIED BY THE
DAIRIES.
THEN WE'RE TOLD YOU HAVE TO
INNOVATE IF YOU'RE ON THE FARM.
FAMILY FARMERS HAVE TO GET WITH
IT.
A POUND OF MEAT OR MILK PRODUCED
VERSUS THE UNIT OF METHANE GAS
RELEASED, THE DUTCH ARE THE MOST
EFFICIENT FARMERS IN THE WORLD.
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
DUTCH FARMING, DAIRY FARMING,
FOR A MODEL FOR HOW TO BE
SUSTAINABLE AND PROMOTE
DEMOCRACY FOR KEEPING FARMERS ON
THE LAND GENERATION AFTER
GENERATION.
>> LAURA: ISN'T THIS A NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUE AS WELL.
>> IT'S SUICIDAL, IT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE.
>> LAURA: SORRY, VICTOR.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> LAURA: AND THAT'S BECAUSE IF
YOU DON'T CONTROL YOUR OWN FOOD
SUPPLY, AS A PEOPLE, YOU -- YOU
ARE DEEPLY VULNERABLE TO
EXPLOITATION AND COERCION FROM
GOVERNMENT AUTHORITIES.
>> AMERICAN AND EUROPEAN FARMERS
ARE THE BEST IN THE WORLD,
THEY'RE THE MOST EFFICIENT.
IT WOULD BE INSANE TO GO WITHOUT
THEM.
I DON'T KNOW WHY WE DO THIS, WE
GOT TO STOP IT.
THESE ARE OUR STRENGTHS, OUR
ASSET FARMERS.